[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
My name is María Ángeles Pallares Cifre,
I am from the mayoress of Canelo Roch, a
municipality of 700 inhabitants in the
province of Castellón, good morning. I am
Jaime Márquez, councilor of  Town Hall
of La Quasas de Valencia with a
population of about 30,000 inhabitants Town
Planning Councilor Employment Training
Mobility European projects Yes Lidia
Ferrera Arias Delegate for
Social Welfare Media and
tenders for the Town Hall of
Cabezas de San Juan in Seville Well,
I'm Manuel Pérez, I'm here  as a veteran from
a town near Valencia And
we have approximately 28,000 inhabitants
and my position is the first
Deputy Mayor
[Music]
Well, the first thing I think I can
contribute to participating in these conferences is
that my neighbors know a little more about what
Europe is because Europe  It is the great
unknown for towns the size of
mine that are so small and it would be very
important for them because to know all
the advantages and everything that Europe brings us
is part of the European Union.
I believe that we are lucky and
fortunate that we are part of
this new Network because I believe that we are going to
know and we are going to have the opportunity
to know first-hand all the
policies that are worked on here in the
community and all the
European policies the citizens of my municipality
see the European institutions and
the decisions that  Here they are taken, they affect
the daily life of all of them,
so what must be done is to transfer
this information from the
European institutions to the citizens and also from the
citizens of the European institutions
This program This Bell program to
build Europe with
local authorities  What I hope from this
program is that we can have a
connection, create a more productive bridge
with Europe to also give the
citizens answers, and
that they see Europe as something practical,
in the end what the city council expects is to
know more about the European institutions
with better understanding of the operation and the
intricacies of especially at the
bureaucratic level at the level of programs because
the European Union is as big as there
can be so many programs
that can be taken advantage of. Well, it is a
very interesting project from which
great things are expected  Not at the end of the day,
local administrations are the
people closest to the citizenship and
the European Union, as I say, is an
institution that protects us, helps us,
benefits us, and well, we have to
create that awareness of Europeans in
each and every one of the municipalities of
Spain.  so that we can take advantage of all
the opportunities that Europe offers us
[Music]